[Music]
okay I'm France and again I'm Frances
Laura and the Chairman we're continuing
this afternoon with the issue is arms
control and security policy the first
speaker is Richard Garwin who is
emeritus IBM Tom Thomas Watson
what are you Thomas Watson fellow
emeritus Thomas Watson Research Center
Richard Garwin is I think everybody's
candidate for the most knowledgeable
most believable most critical and and
reliable a student of
weapons of issues involving weapons and
arms control and it's a very great
pleasure to introduce him richard Garwin
has the title of his talk is nuclear
weapons in the 21st century prospects
and policy
[Applause]
well with that introduction people will
pay attention and find errors in my
speech
as the 20th century comes to a close the
United States and Russia maintained
enormous forces of nuclear weaponry some
12,000 nuclear warheads in the United
States and perhaps 18,000 in Russia each
side deploys some 6,000 strategic
nuclear warheads typically of 500
kilotons that is 500,000 ton 500,000
tons of TNT equivalent or other a
high-explosive this yield is to be
compared with the 15 or 20 kiloton yield
of the only two nuclear weapons exploded
in warfare those that destroyed
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in August 1945 a
mere 20 of these modern warheads
targeted on cities or on military
targets in cities would kill 25 million
Americans or Russians each of these
typical warheads has a destructive area
about nine times that of the first
nuclear weapons
in 1952 of the u.s. tests at his first
large-scale hydrogen bomb prototype
deriving its energy in large part from
thermonuclear fusion of deuterium heavy
hydrogen rather than from the Neutron
induced splitting of uranium-235 or
plutonium
this 10 Megaton monster had an explosive
yield some 600 times that of the first
fission bombs by 1957 with many
additional nuclear explosion tests the
United States had developed a more
usable thermonuclear weapon that weighed
some 400 pounds with a diameter of only
12 inches and a yield of 70 kilotons
much less than the 10 megatons
considerably more than the 15 kilotons
compare this with the first atomic bombs
of some 9,000 pound weight 400 pounds
instead of 9,000 pounds
by 1960 or so us weapons had reached
maturity
at that time we could have built and did
build weapons with the same yield and
weight as the modern w88 warheads that
has been much in the news recently
but many years of further effort allowed
these weapons to be packaged in narrow
conical reentry vehicles about my size
but more pointing about 9 degree
included angle
that could descend through the
atmosphere with sufficient accuracy for
the thermonuclear explosion to crush
Soviet missile silos and that was the
reason for all of this additional effort
the u.s. in 1967 had a peak stockpile of
some 33,000 nuclear warheads and Russia
in 1982 had some 45,000 nuclear weapons
roughly speaking Britain France and
China each have some 300 nuclear weapons
of these China has only about 20
warheads that can be mounted on
long-range rockets to reach the United
States note that 33,000 is 100 times the
number of warheads held by any of these
lesser of the five official nuclear
weapon states now that we have only
about 12,000 we have only about 40 times
as many not 100 times as many the
non-proliferation treaty NPT of 1970
distinguishes the five nuclear weapon
States that is in order of acquiring and
testing nuclear weapons the United
States Russia Britain France and China
from all the rest of the countries of
the world these are the nations that
have tested nuclear weapons by 1964 so
Israel believed to have now more than
100 thermonuclear warheads never tested
and India and Pakistan having conducted
on the order of five nuclear explosions
each in 1980 1998 last year have nuclear
weapons but are not entitled to the non
weapon benefits of the NPT because they
been acquiring nuclear weapons the
non-nuclear weapon states under the NPT
bind themselves not to acquire nuclear
weapons and the nuclear weapon states
are obligated not to transfer nuclear
weapons to the non-nuclear weapon States
or to help them acquire nuclear weapons
in 1995 the members of the NPT extent of
the treaty indefinitely with the
agreement of the five nuclear weapon
states to negotiate and adopt a
comprehensive ban on nuclear explosion
tests
briefly a CTBT Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty which was signed in 1996 and
presented for ratification to the Senate
in 1997
during the administration of John F
Kennedy in 1962 it was predicted that 20
or more states would have nuclear
weapons within a decade or so I believe
that it is the banning of tests in the
atmosphere the limited test ban treaty
of 1963 and the NPT that have kept the
number of such States small together
with the shelter of NATO and the
us-japan Alliance beef Panofsky who is
here in the audience as a member of the
president of Science Advisory Committee
worked energetically and effectively on
the technical aspects of the limited
test ban treaty and on many other of
these arms control and national security
programs and I was involved with the LT
BT on the comprehensive test-ban treaty
as well
these P DS control an enormous
destructive force they don't do it
perfectly but they help the six
kilograms of plutonium little about 13
pounds required for the Nagasaki weapon
could be used to trigger a thermonuclear
weapon of any yield a hundred times a
thousand times the yield of the Nagasaki
weapon hydrogen bombs are a great
extender of the stockpile of fissionable
material so not only can you make much
more powerful bombs you can make a lot
more of them during the 1950s nuclear
weapons were widely deployed used on the
battlefield to destroy enemy troop
concentrations aircraft in the air and
for anti-submarine warfare it was the
day of more bang for a buck
long-range strategic nuclear weapons
were to be delivered by heavy bomber
aircraft with air-to-air refueling that
was mastered early by the United States
and took other countries a long time or
they don't have it yet land-based
intercontinental ballistic missiles soon
to be sheltered in reinforced concrete
silos and submarine launched ballistic
missiles were to augment the bomber
force delivering thousands in fact more
than 10,000 thermonuclear weapons
against targets of choice as testing
validated the smaller thermonuclear
warheads and reentry vehicles that
protected them in coming through the
atmosphere the large rockets were fitted
with dispensing buses so-called that
allowed as many as 14 reentry vehicles
to be deployed on a single missile and
sent against individual targets these
are the so-called Merv's the multiple
independently targeted reentry vehicles
incidentally the bus also increased the
accuracy of the weapon
because it propelled it with low
acceleration and with the proper
velocity without the necessity for
precise timing of the cutoff of the
missile thrust
the Merv's also increased greatly the
difficulty that would be faced by a
system for defending against the nuclear
warheads in flight a ballistic missile
defense so they were
very welcomed by the military
with the advent of accurate Merv's there
was the specter of destruction of an
entire ICBM force by a fraction a mere
fraction of a comparable IC o---- ICBM
force on the other side a first
disarming strike that would preclude
retaliation
this led to the permanent deployment of
SLBMs at sea and submarines that are
difficult to locate it also led to a
capability of launch on warning or
launch under attack and to the necessity
of warning systems that would allow the
land-based missiles to be launched
before they were destroyed
the warning systems and the launch on
warning capability deter attack on the
ICBM force by the clear capability to
destroy population centers in the
attacking country so that was the
prospect in 1972 or so when the United
States and the Soviet Union after about
five years of negotiation signed the ABM
Treaty and a limited offensive agreement
the strategic arms limitation treaty
that limited the number of missile
launchers but it did not limit the
number of warheads because of the
multiple re-entry vehicles nevertheless
had helped to cap and stable stabilize
this confrontation
but it was not until the intermediate
nuclear forces agreement of the 1980s
that eliminated a whole class of US and
Soviet land-based cruise missiles and
ballistic missile launchers worldwide
but not their warheads that major
reductions in nuclear confrontation
occurred
strategic forces were further limited
during the Reagan administration if
start one two launchers capable of
carrying some 6,000 warheads in the
United States and in the Soviet Union
and in a second strategic arms reduction
treaty start to still not ratified by
Russia limiting deployments to 3,000 to
3,500 warheads more or less
with the collapse of the Soviet Union in
1991 Russia did a magnificent job of
repatriating all of the tactical nuclear
weapons and ultimately all of the
strategic warheads from other countries
where they had been deployed including
Belarus Kazakhstan and Ukraine
so that by 1996 there were no nuclear
warheads in these successor states to
the Soviet Union
Presidents Bush and Gorbachev reduced
the nuclear threat by informal agreement
to eliminate many of the tactical
nuclear weapons such as those on surface
ships and start three might limit
deployed strategic warheads to 1,500 on
each side
domestic politics in Russia and in the
United States together with the Russian
resentment of NATO expansion have
delayed the ratification of start 2 by
Russia and the Congress has forbidden
the negotiation of start 3 until start 2
is ratified
arms control is often impeded by a go
slow attitude as if it were the most
dangerous
opportunity in the world this happened
in the beginning when the arms control
and disarmament agency was created and
it has happened recurrently ever since
in 1994 the Nuclear Posture review of
the US Department of Defense
emphasized the importance of retaining
10,000 or so strategic nuclear warheads
as a hedge against failure of the start
process and those strategic warheads in
excess of start whatever levels are now
apparently prized as a reserve force or
a means of substituting warheads in case
of problems that may arise with
individual warheads or a class of
warheads as time goes on
unfortunately this legitimizes the
retention by Russia of any number of
nuclear weapons at a time when Russia no
longer has the means or the focus to
protect them properly against theft or
diversion
Russia is the only nation with nuclear
forces capable of destroying the United
States as a society and it is irrational
to prize the possession of US forces of
negligible marginal utility above the
reduction of Russian capability a
seemingly seemingly possible argument to
maintain a hedge or a reserve conceals
an inability to move to improve US
security the Clinton administration that
was unable to move in the Nuclear
Posture review did however gradually
implement a coup operative threat
reduction program initiated by senator
Sam Nunn and Richard Lugar that has been
spending some four hundred million
dollars per year to secure nuclear
materials in Russia and the former
Soviet Union while reductions of nuclear
weapons are stalled by the economic and
political disarray in Russia by the lack
of leadership in the United States and
the inability of the congressional
leadership to recognize the magnitude of
the nuclear threat to the United States
and to support the process of reducing
it
but there are other threats besides the
existing nuclear weapons in Russia and
these are related to the proliferation
of nuclear weapons
the general advance and spread of
technology permits the accomplishment of
new tasks and makes that of old ones
easier even trivial a
roomful of IBM punched card machines
calculating at 10 operations per second
sufficed to design the first efficient
bombs while a single PC costing four
thousand dollars now provides a billion
operations per second on your desk more
computing power than was used to design
any of the modern thermonuclear weapons
the non-proliferation treaty embodies
the judgment of the five nuclear weapon
States and the vast majority of others
that their security is improved by
preventing the spread of nuclear weapons
not only States but non-state groups
could acquire nuclear weapons if they
desired by theft or by building them
they do not primarily because they don't
want them or because they are unable to
obtain the fissionable material high
enriched uranium or plutonium or to
produce it themselves
this enriched uranium and plutonium have
been produced specifically for the
weapons programs in the nin the nuclear
weapon States and
high-enriched uranium in South Africa to
build six modern Hiroshima type weapons
that were dismantled when South Africa
in the early 1990s decided to join the
NPT so here is an example of a country
that acquired its indigenous nuclear
opens which would in my opinion have
worked quite well but decided that they
were more secure as a non-nuclear weapon
state
about 100 tons of plutonium have been
separated in the civil nuclear power
programs of France Japan and some other
states it would take less than ten
kilograms of this so-called civil
plutonium to make a nuclear weapon
without significantly more difficulty
than would be involved in the use of
so-called military plutonium some 10,000
nuclear weapons could thus be produced
and each of these could be a
thermonuclear weapon
those who separate plutonium from the
irradiated fuel for profit do it really
quite well in plants that are very well
operated but they return the plutonium
and the separated radioactive material
to the country of origin so Japan now
has tens of tons of plutonium in storage
there and Germany presumably has some as
well and other countries that
participate in this reprocessing of
civil reactor fuel
at least 100 tons of military plutonium
and 1000 tons of enriched uranium are
surplus to the weapon programs of the US
and Russia over 20 years Russia is
selling 500 tons of high-enriched
uranium enough for some 20,000 nuclear
weapons to the United States for about
12 billion dollars
the US has no need for this as military
material and in fact under the terms of
the contract must devote it to several
purposes this material will be used in
the civil nuclear power program it would
fuel 100 power reactors about the number
of the United States has for some 5
years
there are other options the US could buy
Russian military plutonium the US could
buy Russian nuclear weapons for that
matter Bill Gates could buy Russian
nuclear weapons and contribute them to
the civil economy and I think that some
of these large-scale contributions
really ought to be thought seriously
about while the stock is still up there
in order to contribute to to the next
generation and to succeeding generations
I
remember about 15 years ago I suppose
with the end of the Cold War approaching
at a meeting at Cambridge University we
were wondering what to do about the
military-industrial complex the
aerospace complex in the United States
it's not very profitable but maybe a
hundred billion dollars a year goes into
it at four or five percent profit it's
less profitable actually than normal
business few percent profit all the
Treasury would need to do is to put away
a hundred billion dollars in one year in
Treasury bonds and then use the income
to pay the profits of the industry that
is by it all up so the Russians could
buy the US industry the US could buy US
industry u.s. could buy Russian industry
and the managers at least and the owners
of the companies would make out just as
well and more surely as them they had
before but for some reason we didn't do
this and we have much larger programs of
all kinds that we don't need I think it
has something to do with congressional
elections
in India's decision to test its nuclear
weapons in 1998 they had had a single
nuclear test in 1974 and to incorporate
nuclear weapons into its military forces
has led to its consideration of a full
triad of nuclear forces that is bombers
missiles on the ground missiles in
submarines
together with the corresponding system
of command and control
this in a theater of repeated armed
conflict between India and Pakistan
these nuclear weapons do not threaten
the United States directly but Pakistan
has obtained missiles and technology
from North Korea and the transfer of
nuclear weapons or weapon uranium from
Pakistan to North Korea would reverse
the gains that have been made in
limiting North Korea's nuclear weapon
program and it's missile tests as is
evident in the india-pakistan
confrontation the acquisition of nuclear
weapons by one nation has a direct
impact on its neighbors and with the
spread of long-range missiles it has an
influence on States at a substantial
distance
the future of the non-proliferation
treaty depends on the Comprehensive Test
Ban Treaty which the Senate rejected a
week ago October 13th 1999
the CTBT poses no additional limits on a
non-nuclear weapon state that's a member
of the NPT they're already denying
themselves nuclear weapons so they
couldn't possibly test one without
violating the NPT but the five nuclear
weapon states has signed it have signed
it as has Israel which is not a member
of the NPT the US has not tested since
1992 and China since 1996 in declining
to consent to ratification of the CTBT
senators argued that Russia and China
would conduct clandestine nuclear weapon
explosive tests in violation of the zero
threshold test ban treaty it doesn't
allow any nuclear energy release that
proliferates states would not join the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty and could
test openly that the International
monitoring system to be set up by this
treaty and that is in operation as a
provisional system even supplemented by
US intelligence would might not detect
the smallest tests and they argued that
the u.s. nuclear stockpile could not be
maintained safe and reliable without
nuclear explosion testing
US military leaders and the heads of the
three US nuclear weapon laboratories
support the Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty when it is supplemented by six
safeguards the last of which includes
the promise to
release ourselves from the treaty if
weapon critical to our inventory could
not be certified as reliable or safe
without nuclear testing as I argued in
my testimony to the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee October 7
tiny tests that cannot be detected
confidently under the CTBT would not
militarily disadvantage the United
States and a 4.5 billion annual
stockpile stewardship program of
surveillance analysis and remanufacture
will maintain our nuclear weapons in
pristine state for many decades
it's not just that we test the
components of nuclear weapons and hope
that when they're put together the whole
thing will work no we have some
precision
vehicles which are the nuclear weapons
themselves but just with the plutonium
removed that are sent all the way to
Mach targets by missile or bombs and
they work if they don't work then we
know a lot more than in the days when we
were conducting nuclear tests because
they do not test the other parts of the
system many components essential
component of a nuclear weapon are not
involved at all in an underground
nuclear test the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty cannot
enter into force without us ratification
beyond that it needs a signature of
India Pakistan and North Korea former
ambassadors to India and Pakistan Frank
Wisner and Bob Oakley write that without
u.s. ratification India will test
further to develop a true thermonuclear
weapon and Pakistan will match India's
tests one for one
China would find it difficult to refrain
from testing under those circumstances
having had only 45 nuclear tests
themselves the United States has had
more than 1,000 the leaders of France
Britain and Germany have imported the
United States to ratify the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty in a very
unusual
article in The New York Times
further development of US nuclear
weapons will not counter proliferation
the
US has by far the greatest and the most
flexible military capability in the
world and its nuclear weapon technology
is the most advanced more than a
thousand US nuclear explosion tests
contributed to this the logical lead but
effective nuclear weapons of 1957
vintage that I mentioned before or even
the fish and weapons of 1950 half a
century ago are enough to destroy
millions of people this threat cannot be
contained by further nuclear weapons
development and nuclear tests it must be
constrained by arms control by
deterrence of acquisition or use of
nuclear weapons and if necessary by
destruction of the nuclear weapons
before they can be used or by defense
against their delivery
it is natural to want to rely solely on
US actions to protect a u.s. security
but technological realities get in the
way
there are many means to deliver nuclear
weapons and long-range missiles are only
one the Rumsfeld Commission of which I
was a member
warned in 1998 that North Korea Iran or
Iraq could have ICBMs within five years
if they mounted a well-financed an
urgent program to obtain them but we
also noted that it would be far easier
for any of these countries to use
short-range cruise missiles available by
the tens of thousands in the world or
ballistic missiles short-range ballistic
missiles from a cargo ship to attack US
cities
not having any hope or desire to destroy
all of us society with a few nuclear
weapons on wrong long-range missiles
they would have to choose appropriate
targets and they might as well choose
the important ports and population
centers along the coast and use the
easier more reliable and more accurate
delivery means of cruise missiles or
short-range ballistic missiles in this
era of global trade it would be even
easier to detonate a nuclear weapon in a
US Harbor or to spread biological
warfare agents from an automobile or
light aircraft exposing a city or
military base much more effectively than
by the use of missiles of uncertain
reliability and accuracy I
mentioned the countering of such systems
by defense
and indeed Congress has long demanded a
national missile defense we deployed one
once in
1974 the safeguard system with 100
nuclear-armed interceptors deployed at
Grand Forks North Dakota with one
long-range acquisition radar and a
missile defense radar there this had had
a checkered career it had originated in
the Johnson administration as a city
protection system a light area defense
against Chinese ICBMs which in fact did
not materialize for 11 years after the
speech announcing the development and
deployment of that system and by the
time the Nixon administration took
office it was clear that there would not
be a race of people in cities to be
defended but I raced out from under the
nuclear umbrella so never mind that the
program was to defend population it had
so much momentum that it was going to go
forward for some purpose and it its name
was changed to protect the guilty it was
now going to defend Minuteman silos the
retaliatory force against Russia not
against China
of course it wouldn't have done that
either because the Minuteman silos were
hard and tough whereas the radars were
very vulnerable and so they could easily
have been overcome so 21 billion dollars
in current dollars 12 billion dollars in
10-year dollars down the drain
however there supposed to be a rosy side
to this because
Jerry Smith our ambassador to the
to the ABM Treaty talks and the limited
offensive agreement talks had his arm
twisted sufficiently vigorously that he
wrote home and said that he needed the
deployment of this system in order to
get the Russians to agree to the
proposed treaty
now in 1999 the Clinton administration
has for two years been developing a
system based on a different kind of
interceptor not nuclear-armed but
so-called hit-to-kill which would strike
these warheads and collide with them in
the vacuum of outer space it would have
advanced radars and some facility is
deployed in space for observation to
counter four or five or if you've been
paying attention in the last few weeks a
few tens of warheads from a rogue state
these emerging missile states like North
Korea Iraq and Iran it has also always
stated also that this proposed system
would have some capability against a
small accidental or unauthorized launch
of long-range missiles from China or
Russia unfortunately this system will
have zero effectiveness even against a
few warheads launched from North Korea
North Korea would not go to all the
trouble of making ICBMs and putting
nuclear warheads or biological warfare
agents on their missiles launching them
at the United States provoking certain
retaliation without taking measures to
have them militarily effective if
possible and
unfortunately it is easy to do that to
send a hundred kilograms of anthrax or
other VW agent against the city is to
waste delivery capability it comes down
in one place and then there's an arrow
plume in which everybody will die but
the rest of the people will not be
exposed
much better from the attackers point of
view is to repackage this material in
the form of bomblets each of which
weighs a pound or so and as the missile
comes up through the atmosphere and the
rocket engines shut off then these
bomblets can be dispersed easy to do
with a rotating payload and you then
split the shroud and the individual
Obama lets come off they have their
individual heat shield so they can
re-enter the atmosphere and when they
strike the ground at low speed just as
if they were dropped from an elevator or
an aircraft we have designs that we
published in the nineteen fifty in a
Declassified us biological weapons
programs that shows you how to
disseminate this stuff to maximum
effectiveness
so it would be an anomaly it would be
irrational
it would not be sensible and it won't
happen for North Korea to send over a
unitary warhead that has any possibility
of being intercepted if they are going
to deal with biological warfare agents
but perhaps they will have nuclear
weapons mating and untested perhaps
nuclear weapon when an unreliable one
with an unreliable and inaccurate ICBM
they might do that but then they would
want to make sure if possible that the
nuclear weapon would not be intercepted
and unfortunately that's very easy their
nuclear weapon would be larger than I am
it might be the size of two of these
lecterns but it would be small compared
with the size of the room and so all
they would need to do is to have an
enclosing balloon made of thin
aluminized plastic which you can buy at
the party favors store and you lay it
out to this plastic and with adhesive
self-adhesive tape or a heat sealer you
make it into a big doesn't have to be
round balloon and so some place within
that big balloon which will be inflated
as soon as the warhead is separated from
the rocket there will be the warhead if
the ballistic missile defense system
works perfectly that the interceptor
will strike the imposing balloon it will
not strike the warhead
both of these threats could be countered
by a missile defense system that works
in boost phase and it seems feasible to
deploy a joint us-russian system south
of Vladivostok or on US military cargo
ships in the Japan Basin to counter and
eventual North Korean ICBM threaten but
it would be foolish to rely on
countering nuclear attack if it were
possible to prevent the acquisition of
nuclear weapons the
question is whether the 21st century
will be one of nuclear weapons for all
or of nuclear weapon restraint a sick
Russian president deep suspicion in the
Russian Duma lack of leadership in the
United States keep us from recognizing
and dealing with the threat to u.s.
security posed by nuclear weapons and by
the proliferation in an era of domestic
political confrontation there's also no
agreement on the path to be taken
President Clinton has emphasized that
the US will continue to abide by its
signature on the Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty despite the fact that it has not
ratified the treaty so domestically the
failure of the CTBT has no impact but
internationally it does
the greatest threat to US and global
security is the enormous Russian nuclear
arsenal we have to get our priorities
right
strengthening Russian control reducing
the size of the Arsenal and erecting
higher barriers to its leakage are the
highest priority if relations between
the United States and the People's
Republic of China should deteriorate to
downright enmity as might occur through
initiatives on the side of the Chinese
or gratuitously by our demonization of
China China could evolve to pose a
serious threat this is far better
averted than countered you should not
welcome a nuclear arms race even with a
lesser competitor the US must have exert
every effort to bring India and Pakistan
into the CTBT in order that the
non-proliferation treaty not fall apart
an
urgent and feasible US agenda for
reducing the nuclear threat in a
multipolar world such as we have would
include the recognition that US security
is secured more by limiting the threat
than by increasing us arms it would
include proper hearings leading to a
better understanding of the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty and to its
radication ratification and entry into
force perhaps with other understandings
between the Congress and the
administration
they could include extending the start
regime with Russia to include all
nuclear warheads and nuclear weapon
usable materials not just delivery
vehicles and limiting the total to 2,000
warhead equivalents on each side that
could be done very quickly the remainder
would be demilitarized and committed
irreversibly to the civil economy long
before they could be dismantled
if Britain France and China limit their
nuclear weapons to 300 each the US and
Russia could drop to a thousand US
weapons would be largely deployed as
single warhead ICBMs in silos on
submarine launched ballistic missiles
and a relatively few on bombers Russian
weapons would likely be deployed largely
on ICBMs either mobile or in silos we
shouldn't care
just as the US commitment to NATO and to
the security of Japan has facilitated
German Germany and Japan's non-nuclear
weapon status so what a commitment of
the United States and other nuclear
weapon States through the United Nations
or regional agreements to provide
security guarantees of non-nuclear
weapon States against nuclear attack
other than arms control treaties there
are less formal actions that can be
taken by presidents in the context of
similar or comparable actions on the
other side such as the bush gorbachev
reduction of tactical nuclear weaponry
these could reduce the likelihood or the
damage of war by accident or
misunderstanding since the large nuclear
forces of the United States and Russia
exist mostly for some future and
unspecified eventualities removing them
from alert would be a useful step half
of the silo-based ICBMs could be covered
with 50 feet of earth but it is not so
simple to verifiably the alert
submarine-launched ballistic missiles a
joint u.s. Russian working group should
be established to evaluate such options
without a commitment to implementing
them
we should continue to keep weapons out
of space and to ban tests of anti
satellite systems that's another area
that is ripe for confrontation it is
incredible to believe that it's
incredible that Russia even it is
diminished state would permit the United
States to put in weapons that would
dominate not only nuclear but
conventional war that is orbiting lasers
that the Air Force hankers for without
threatening them with space mines or
with that he saw lights and we have very
important resources
civil and military in space now to keep
watch on the world and maintain
stability I worked with Henry Kendall
and Curt got freedom the mid-1980s in
the Star Wars era to do something about
that foolish and dangerous initiative
but our job is not finished
to do any of these things to do our arms
control treaties one needs to get the
Congress the Senate on board but to do
these informal things one needs to have
presidential leadership
in a new administration whether it's
democratic or republican I believe that
the Defense Department and the other
elements of the government have an
obligation to review u.s. national
security and I hope that we do a better
job this time than we did with the
Nuclear Posture review
we need to do some other things to trim
up the United Nations and the
International mechanisms for instance
the conference on Disarmament which
prides itself on being the sole
negotiating body for arms control can
handle only one topic at a time but
there are many more problems than that
and it's all too easy to fill the agenda
of the conference on Disarmament with
with with something of lesser importance
so that it cannot attack the problems of
major importance it would be a tragedy
if the arms control agenda could be
re-energized only following the nuclear
destruction of cities in Pakistan and
India it would be too late if the
us-russian nuclear confrontation a
residue of the Cold War were unleashed
by accident or inadvertence
thank
you